the fans we're not calling you Holley
this summer no no dang it David David
[Laughter]
I'm gonna kill him not really but dang
it David no that is David in a nutshell
that whole like he's Beth I'm like you
sassy little you really want to know how
people were feeling about you search
Beth not Halle on Twitter but if you
want to see nice things I need to find
David so this is bad David apparently
America knows me now as Beth well you
know when I came back in the house I
remembered everybody's name including
yours he's just switched at the time
there's something about you to me right
like I met a Beth of 10 years ago that's
the most beautiful woman in the world
and so when I came in and I started
talking to her I was like this is so
beautiful you just became Beth and where
am i from
congratulations Mickey you have one big
brother
second place not too shabby
how we feeling it's not first but I will
take it mostly because I don't have a
choice but I would take it there's still
a check that comes with it yeah I'm not
hey I'm not mad at that check and I've
saved a lot of money this summer I spent
nothing because I've done nothing so at
least there's that all right so you got
cat Jess and Nicole's votes yeah
did any of the votes surprise you well I
figured if I was up there against Mickey
it would be a tough go I wasn't sure I
actually was surprised by sis and Kristy
and Tommy I didn't know where they was
land because they are such gamers and I
didn't really show enough of my cards
with them on the game that I was playing
cuz I was so low-key so I wasn't sure
where they would go
those were the wild cards for me this
was really the only one I was surprised
by yeah I think the audience was a
little surprised by this - yeah I mean I
did vote for Victor but Mickey put her
up I mean yeah it's a complicated game
but your boy won yes so it's kind of
like you won - you're walking out with
it's not well you're welcome now you're
walking out with maybe some love yeah
where where do we see this thing going
well before anything romantically
happens between Mickey and I we
established we're gonna be friends
forever we started off as friends I
don't know where life is gonna take us
after here we have been very transparent
since the get-go we are going to take
everything one day at a time
navigate life outside of these walls but
regardless of whether things happen
romantically outside of here or not we
will be friends forever that we know so
we're entering the real world as friends
know we're still still romantically well
like if it doesn't work oh that's fine
you know it's like a no worries
situation if at any point offended you
on a personal level I'm very sorry you
had to sit next to Mickey while he faced
some maybe harsh truths about this
season
sitting there what was going through
your head how are you processing that
these are things I mean we have a lot of
downtime over 99 days and these are all
things that I've worried about I didn't
know specifically you know I knew that
we would face hard stuff I am devastated
that he does have to deal with that some
of the racist remarks surprised me just
because I was there for his
decision-making in that and it was very
game oriented and also it just didn't
occur to me you know what I mean as far
as the degrading to women stuff I know
how he treats me I've never seen him act
like that towards anyone I just know how
he treats me and he is so motivated I
mean he's a very big character and gets
very worked up so let's not ignore that
back so I get that he's just he's making
you know he's a lot but to me he was
always supportive and I'm proud of you
and like motivating and even today it
was like all right let's do kit out
let's battle you know what I mean so he
was always really empowering to me so
that's all I know but man I'm I don't
know it's wrong it was strange to see
someone who just won this show walk out
looking almost defeated so it'll be
interesting to see I mean he luckily he
gets to go home watch it process it
himself
yes and a lot will come I'm sure I'll
have a lot more to say once I realize
exactly you know I just know his big
personality but I don't know what was
taken you know and in the context so I'm
sure I will have more to say on it once
I included once you're gonna watch yeah
tonight's about celebrating yeah there's
some weird stuff to celebrate too like
Kat and Nick are together no wait what
whoa like what oh and the world like
knows this cat and I know each other
right so there's also that um okay
didn't see that coming I thought maybe
okay I had some other speculations what
was that I maybe I'm actually talking to
say that because I don't want to get in
trouble with my friends who we're injury
I had other speculations but I
definitely did not see that coming
that was a surprise Oh Kathryn she said
she's gonna be avoiding Bella tonight
which i think is the smart move yeah
yeah I would that was a no the tough
girl I would and she does not tolerate
but yes so I also don't know the details
of like anything so I'm glad I was not
involved in the jury drama I will say
that much I'm very glad you're gonna
learn a lot tonight you guys are gonna
be drinking tonight some troops are
gonna come out great all right you've
got some money in your pocket now what
are we doing with it how are we spending
that money well Mickey and I decided a
while ago that we're gonna go take a
trip we want to plan trips where we go
somewhere tropical and then somewhere
icy cold will kind of be like the
opposite back and forth so we were
talking enlike daydreaming and it's a
house so we talked about maybe Bora Bora
so maybe you will go to Bora Bora
anything that involves travel for now
just so I can clear my mind recenter and
then go back to work I miss working and
being productive I really miss being
productive so I'll go back to work soon
but for right now travel somewhere you
gotta hit the reset button a little bit
last question I know you just stepped
out would you go back play again it is
so much harder than you would ever
believe being in that house so much
harder in every way possible but would I
do it again yes because second place is
great but it's not good enough and I
loved fighting I loved competing oh my
gosh those comps are fun the downtime is
excruciating and boring and full of
anxiety and it is like panic room in
there but yeah I would do it again all
right
you just got to fit in Bora Bora an icy
place maybe a few wine safaris then even
get back in that house yes oh yeah I
need I need to go and live and be free
for a little while before I am locked
away again but
I would do it eventually eventually
congratulations
welcome back to the real world
[Music]